なんかさんにすごい商品が出たみたいですこちら究極の卵かけご飯あの子まで機能内蔵
んね自動で行ってくれるのなんかねこうこれがあるだけで究極の卵かけご飯を作って
くれるみたいでございますかマークかけご飯たような本当に美味しいんですよ
マジで冗談抜きでおいしいし東京に以来打撲
外に出たくないんですよ東京人多くて怖いなあんまり外に出たらないんでられる室内で
なんかメッシュを済ませようと思ってって所卵わかってるんで究極って言ってますけど
ね究極に美味しい卵かけご飯を作れるんだったらそれを食べてみたいというわけで今回
買ってみましたやっぱり
機械でだった卵は一味違う未来が不安になる一言ですね間取り図を挙げてみましょう
あー中身はシンプルなんか普通にゴリゴリの
なにこれこれでなんかも卵を割ることも可能だし調べた君は分離させるのもついてるし
豊作回転する場所もついてるらしいですわぁを作り方一つで全然味とかねのふわふわ感
が違ってくるねちょっと結構実は期待してたりしましたこれ髪は何ないまでずっと僕
興味を
っててようやく注文してたんですけどとりあえず
作って3日まず卵をセットします
ってああ後に生卵を入れてのセットしますでいいのかなえ大丈夫本当にとっても不安な
んだかこれでこれを押すともタバコははれるみたいですできますよ軽くたたくんの
軽くたたきます
ますっ
ああああああ
ねちょっとあっても振る舞って何にもん
あっぱちょびっとはれとるやんけこうじゃないこれで行ったら卵を割るって書いてある
んだ
やってやっほびっくりしちゃってきちゃっとできちゃったデータ
6つ綺麗に出来てるからこっちにおすごいちゃんとたものからだけ残ってるもうこの
時点で結構感動なんですけどここに君があるんですけど下に白身がたまっててその白身
を公開呈させてすぎ泡立ててくれるらしいです
いいいい
dea
ああああああ
おいて a
落ちないなぁか全然打てないじゃんっ
[音楽]
ブーバーそれじゃないでしょうか
はいうんわーもうすごいヨーグルト
気楽に人間の力では不可能なレベルの白身になっておりません
これほんとにすごいなこれをかけていきます
これ自治貸さなかった
まあて機械が取っちゃったってもうすごいな肉をねぇ答えになってますねもう
worth 後夫はなにこれ女卵かけご飯見たことね皆さん白身ですよ君にを載せて
いきまーすっ ahkah こりゃあねぇこれはウマいぞテュ気楽に違うという理由で
きましたーー
ずっと有名ずあって俺こんな商品見たことねーんだもうこれ本物ですはこんな白い見た
ことないもん
早速どれぐらいなぜなのか食べてみましょうよだれ次屋2
よだれすごいコンポ出るぞよだれだらけマックスむらいてほしい
下ります
ていません
すっ
あっあえっ馬をは立つがすごい何にビールなんか泡がちゃんと美味しいですね本当に
でっ
まあ卵を何に使うかにもよると思うんですけども
白身のこの二ボブワーカーも本当に嬉しく思いますクリーミーになっている杯だけで
究極卵を組んでご飯とても美味しくございましたばこれだけだと普通の卵かけご飯と
究極卵かけとかどっちが美味しいかっていうのがよくわかんないと思うのでじゃあ自分
でつけた普通の卵かけご飯も準備しました
この2つの今から一口食べさせてもらって究極の卵かけご飯の方がおいしいというのは
すぐわかれば
ホテルも完全に美味しいってわかると思うんだよっそこでてみましょう
を
ずっとはいはいガーン
はぁ
あぜっていうね行く頭をかけ後バーン
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ